- You ready?
You all set?
I got you.
Mm.
♪ ♪
Hey, people.
Kevin Hart here,
and I'm comfortable.
Real comfortable.
I got my shoes off.
I got my thighs out.
Why am I comfortable?
I'll tell you why, because I'm
in Birmingham, Alabama.
It's a city with good people
and people who love to laugh.
How do I know that?
Because I've done comedy
here several times, man.
This penthouse
that I'm in right now?
The first penthouse
that I've ever stayed in.
I ain't lying, 'cause I've
stayed--that's a lie.
I can't lie to you guys.
I--I wanted to stay
in this penthouse,
when I was coming to Birmingham,
but I couldn't afford it,
so I stayed in the junior suite.
It's not about me.
Let's not even
make this about me.
We're here to find new talent.
The new generation of comedians
that are coming--
What are you--
what are you doing?
- Have you seen a phone?
I'm trying to
order room service.
- Brother, I'm doing--
- Where the phone at?
- I'm doing the intro.
- Hey, you got cable?
- I'm doing the intro!
- My room ain't got cable.
- Ju--
This is not your room.
It's mine.
- You right, you right,
you right, you right...
- Where the phone?
- This is my room.
- I ain't got no phone.
- What--? I said it's--
[yells]
- There go the phone.
There go the phone.
- Now I got the phone.
- Ha, how y'all get
keys to my room?
That's the question
of the day.
People are gonna think
that we--that we're grouping up,
but that's not the case,
'cause I'm a star.
We're here to talk
about the new gen--
- Kev, how much you say
I got to put in on this?
- I said get your ass
to the room, Harry.